The first wave of series slated to debut on the
Disney+ streaming service promise the return of
fan favorites and big-screen staples, bringing
some MCU adventure straight to your living room.
But one show in particular is set apart by an
air of mystery and a strange title: What If...?
For quite some time now, we've all
been asking two important questions:
"what if" and "when?" Well, we definitely
know the answer to the latter. On July 8,
2021, Marvel dropped the first official
trailer for their new series and promised
that the show would start streaming on August
11. For those without their calendars nearby,
that's a Wednesday — a tradition that was started
with the first episode of "Loki" back in June. And
taking a cue from the God of Mischief, all Disney+
MCU series will air on Wednesday going forward.
As for how many episodes we can expect, in 2019,
ComicBook.com reported that Kevin Feige said
we're getting 10 episodes for Season 1. So,
prepare yourself for the 10-episode
series to kick off on August 11.
"I want it! Come on, gimme it.
Gimme it. Come on, give me it."
At the D23 Expo in 2019, Bryan Andrews was
announced as the director of "What If...?." You
may not have heard of him, but he's someone with
an impressive MCU history. Andrews worked in the
art department drawing storyboards for "Ant-Man,"
"Doctor Strange," and "Avengers: Endgame." "What
If...?" will mark his first directing credit in 20
years, since directing the animated series "Jackie
Chan Adventures" in 2001. Andrews is widely
known for his work on "Samurai Jack," which
earned him two Emmys for Outstanding Individual
Achievement In Animation in 2005 and 2017.
A.C. Bradley serves as the lead writer on "What
If...?" and has a relatively short résumé in
the business. Bradley wrote one episode of
"Arrow" in 2014, in addition to 23 episodes
of Netflix's "Trollhunters: Tales of Arcadia"
and 26 episodes of "3Below: Tales of Arcadia."
As is normal with any MCU project, Kevin Feige
serves as an executive producer. Additionally,
Laura Karpman was tapped to create the
score for the "What If...?" episodes.
The composer has worked on the critically
acclaimed HBO series "Lovecraft Country."
Something MCU fans were delighted to
hear when "What If...?" was announced
was the confirmation that almost
every actor we know and love from
the universe would be voicing the
characters they portray onscreen.
Sadly, that doesn't include Robert Downey Jr., who
will not be returning, with someone else voicing
Tony Stark instead. And at the time of this video,
Benedict Cumberbatch, Chris Evans, and Scarlett
Johansson aren't confirmed in the series to voice
their characters of Doctor Strange, Steve Rogers,
and Black Widow, even though we know those
characters are returning in some form or another.
At the same time, rumors suggest there will be
an exciting story surrounding Natasha Romanoff.
Who ends up voicing these characters will be quite
the surprise when their respective episodes air.
One of the first big reveals that came with the
"What If...?" official announcement at SDCC 2019
was the identity of the series' narrator. For
10 episodes, "Westworld" star Jeffrey Wright
will lend his voice to the series as Uatu, the
Watcher. We got our first look at Uatu, who's
a mysterious bald being who resembles a man, in
the Disney+ featurette "Expanding the Universe."
We know from the comics that Uatu is a part
of an ancient race known as the Watchers,
who simply observe all events throughout history.
First appearing in 1963's "Fantastic Four" #13,
the Watchers' goal was to help less evolved
species since they were so technically advanced.
After sharing nuclear technology with the
people of another planet, the population
decimated themselves, prompting the Watchers
to never intervene with civilizations again.
Wright, known for his smooth voice,
will voice Uatu as he watches over
these what-could-have-been events on Earth
that involve many of our favorite heroes.
The "What If" comics have been around since the
'70s, with the first issue kicking off in 1977.
"What If" #1 had the subtitle "What If Spider-Man
Had Joined the Fantastic Four?" and started a
successful run of alternate storylines with famous
characters. The volumes are also narrated by Uatu,
who, at the beginning of the issue, details
canonical events readers are familiar with
and then introduces a "what if" moment that
changes the story entirely. The rest of the
issue follows that new alternate story, as
Uatu continues to narrate what never was.
The upcoming television show
looks to be using the basic
concept of the comic series with
the added twist of an MCU focus.
Expect to see familiar moments from your favorite
Marvel movies twisted by one important change.
Season 1 of "What If...?" will consist of
10 episodes, which doesn't seem like enough
room to explore all the possibilities
inherent in the premise. Unsurprisingly,
a second season has already been confirmed.
In a 2019 interview with BuzzFeed Brasil,
Kevin Feige confirmed that the "What
If...?" series would go beyond 10 episodes,
and he's very excited at what
the studio has put together.
"I'm very happy that we're doing a 'What If...?'
series for Disney+ right now, and I've seen
most of them. We have 10 for Season 1. We're
already working on the next ten for Season 2."
This is the first MCU Disney+ series to confirm
a second season, and it seems like the show could
go even further past that. As the MCU evolves
and more characters are introduced to us on the
big screen, it opens the door to even more "What
If" comics storylines the studio can draw from.
Here's one thing that we know 100% right out of
the gate — Episode 1 will follow Peggy Carter,
voiced by Hayley Atwell. Feige
also told BuzzFeed Brasil,
"We've revealed one that is very exciting.
We've talked about it for years, which is
the one where Peggy Carter gets the Super
Soldier serum and becomes Captain Carter.
That's the very first episode, and I'm excited
for people to see that. I'm excited to see the
finished version of that, and I'm
excited for the world to see it."
Also detailed in the "What If...?" trailers
is a battle between two Doctor Stranges. This
particular episode will follow what would have
happened if there was an evil Sorcerer Supreme,
but we expect the plot to have a much
more precise point of divergence,
which causes the shift in the story.
We suspect this particular episode will
pull partly from "What If?" Vol. 1 #18,
where Doctor Strange becomes a disciple
of Dormammu. Released in 1979, the comic
follows an arrogant Stephen Strange whose hands
are healed by Baron Mordo through black magic.
Mordo works for the interdimensional being as his
follower, and he introduces Strange to the baddie.
The story takes Doctor Strange through
a long journey through self-discovery,
which he finds much quicker in the
character's introductory MCU film.
Before his untimely death in 2020, Chadwick
Boseman participated in "What If...?" by lending
his voice to T'Challa. There are a few glimpses
of the Wakandan in the trailer for the series,
and it looks like this retelling
will imagine what would happen if
the Ravagers from "Guardians of the Galaxy"
kidnapped T'Challa from Earth and not Peter
Quill. Instead of becoming Black Panther,
T'Challa would take on the role of Star-Lord,
eventually leading the Ravagers,
according to The Illuminerdi.
"Who?"
"Star-Lord, man. Legendary outlaw?"
This won't be the only appearance of T'Challa
in "What If...?," however. Kevin Feige revealed
to "Emmy Magazine" that Boseman came into the
studio and recorded his voice for four different
episodes, so we can expect multiple MCU heroes
to pop up more than once in the animated series.
We're also going to be getting a
zombified version of Steve Rogers,
according to released footage. Taking down this
Captain America terror will be his best buddy,
Bucky Barnes, whose mission is to
prevent the spread of this zombie virus.
It should be noted that there are no zombie
storylines in the "What If" comics, but the
undead did have a run on the Marvel pages in 2005.
"Marvel Zombies" Vol. 1 was a limited series that
saw the entire superhero population zombified, and
they subsequently ate the entire human race. There
have since been other volumes and spins on the
five-story series, all equally as gruesome. While
there is no apparent connection between zombie
Cap and living Bucky, it'll be exciting to see
how this story plays out on "What If...?" and what
event this deviated from in the duo's history.
T'Challa won't be the only nod to Wakanda in
"What If...?" In the series' official trailer,
we witness a young Killmonger save Tony Stark
from the missile that blows up in the original
"Iron Man." We then watch as Killmonger rides on
a rhino and seemingly fights in a war for Wakanda.
However, this time, it appears that Killmonger
will be the rightful heir to the throne.
According to "ScreenRant," a toy leak has
revealed a Funko Pop figure that displays the
"Black Panther" villain as king of Wakanda, but
it's not just his new title that's shocking. He's
holding a blade in one hand and the severed head
of what's suspected to be Ultron in the other.
We can't wait to see how this one plays
out and what scenario could have caused
an instance where Killmonger and Ultron
came face to face. In the MCU, "Avengers:
Age of Ultron" and "Black Panther" are set a year
apart, with the vengeful AI getting destroyed
before we took a trip to Wakanda. Killmonger was
obviously around at the time of Ultron's creation,
just a bit younger, and it seems likely that he
sought out the AI once he learned of its creation
by Tony Stark and Bruce Banner. If he is a force
for good and a strong king of Wakanda remains
to be seen, but it would be a nice twist
to see him as a hero and not the villain.
The series' official trailer delivered
all sorts of superhero goodness,
and while we aren't exactly sure where the series
is headed, we're definitely excited to find out.
For example, at one point, we see Thor fighting
off Ultron's legions ... in Las Vegas of all
place. We're assuming this might be connected to
some interesting merch details that were leaked in
April 2021. According to "CBR," there's evidently
an official T-shirt and hat that both bear the
image of "Party Thor." While there are more than a
handful of Thor stories from the "What If" comics,
nothing seems to fall in line with
whoever the heck Party Thor is.
No matter what this story is
about, it's going to be a riot.
The trailer also shows us a young Shuri in
action, Spider-Man arriving on the scene,
Ego the Living Planet giving us a villainous
grin, and the return of Howard the Duck.
"Gross."
On top of all that, it appears that Clint
Barton has somehow received a heavy dose
of gamma radiation as it appears Hawkeye is
turning into the Hulk. It also looks like Loki
is leading an army of Asgardians against
Earth, and perhaps most interestingly,
there's a shot of Thor, Black Panther, Star-Lord,
and Gamora holding Thanos' double-bladed sword
striking an "Avengers"-style pose
in the middle of a desolated city.
As for Thanos' favorite daughter, we've
definitely heard some interesting theories
about her character. According to The Illuminerdi,
Gamora's storyline may follow her as she tracks
down her new enemy — Tony Stark. This
plot point hasn't been confirmed yet,
but if that does indeed pan out,
that would be a fascinating twist.
Last but not least, as we previously mentioned,
Natasha Romanoff is showing up in the series,
alongside some version of the Hulk. And
according to another Illuminerdi report,
this episode will allegedly see Black Widow
as one of the only survivors after Ultron
successfully destroyed Earth in 2015.
No matter how crazy these stories seem,
"What If...?" is going to be one of
the most unique MCU properties to date.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite MCU projects are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.